>> GRACE: Hi. My name is Grace. I work on
the Android Browser. Today, I'm going to show
you some tricks on Android Browser. You want
to go visit your friend via Google. You found
that address on the website but it's not highlighted,
so you cannot click it. Don't worry. This
is Android Browser. You just need to click
the address. It will take you directly to
the map. Hit the back, you're back to the
browser. Type the phone number, you go to
the dialer. You can call the phone number.
Now, you know, in the bottom of the browser
you want to scroll to the top. Instead of
skip scrolling, you can use a quick zoom.
Just tap here and then move this window all
the way up to here and then release your finger.
Walla, you're on the top. There, you notice
your paragraph, half of it is off the screen.
Don't worry. Tap on the text, it will move
to the middle of the screen.